Don't overthink it.
Just relax.
Let them see the man underneath.
You know I've been asking myself,
what possible wisdom I could impart to the bright young minds of tomorrow.
Be anyone you want to be.
Figure out what you believe in.
What makes you righteous,
angry.
I believe in you, Sam.
Get to the core of who you really are.
We just cultivate that clean image.
Nigel, my mother told me from an early age to fight for  justice,
protect those who are vulnerable.
This is what we're selling: confidence, hope, optimism.
Your mythology is your best asset.
Be honest about your weaknesses.
Capitalize on your strengths.
Because really you can only be you.
Be you.
Whoever that is.
Thank you.
He's very very good at what he does.
Fooling everyone.
The right man for the job then.
Everyone's got a dark side,
the more you get to see.
There's two FBI agents that want to speak to you.
Whatever mess you're in,
you need to get yourself out of it now.
People are going to know what you really are.
I'd be careful here; sounds like you're fishing.
You'll write this story.
This is about you protecting your ticket to the top.
Sam, about your zipper problem.
People want to believe that you're somehow better than they are.
This is a black and white issue.
They need that fairy tale.
I set out to help people. I never said I was better than them.
Everyone's just waiting for you to win this.
To Sam!
Do whatever you need to do to make it happen.
This is the perfect time
to get used to surprises.
What did you do?
Remember all the goals we set for ourselves? Let's not throw that away.
People still need heroes.
Let's give 'em one.